Guten Tag. Guten Tag. Ich bin der zuständige Art für Sie. Mein Name ist Ensemwe Göckvers.
Bevor wir anfangen, lassen Sie mich bitte zuerst Ihre personische Daten notieren.
Wenn Sie jetzt quasi nicht verstehen, bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach. Okay?
Gerne. Okay.
Erst mal, wie alt sind Sie? Ich heiße Brigitte Müller.
Okay. Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vorname Buch stabilen?
Br, R, I, G, I, T, T, E. Brigitte.
Okay. Und dann mit Doppel L, ja?
Okay. Frau Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Verraten Sie mir Ihr Geburtstab?
Ja, ich bin geboren am 12. Februar 1958.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich heiße 165 groß.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege momentan 71 Kilo.
Frau Müller, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Ich fange wie Kinder.
Ich habe eine Tochter.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Büroangestellte.
Frau Müller, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich habe seit ungefähr drei, vielleicht vier Wochen so Schmerzen im Rücken.
Ja, das kam jetzt so langsam, wurde es mehr und mehr.
Und jetzt habe ich doch starke Schmerzen.
Ich muss sogar Schmerzmittel jetzt nehmen.
Erst mal können wir genau zeigen, wo die Schmerzen sind.
Also im länden Bereich, unterer länden Bereich.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nee, ausstrahlen tun die Schmerzen nicht.
Das ist mehr da oben.
Können Sie mir genau beschreiben, wie die Schmerzen sind?
Sind sie sehr dumm oder stechend oder brennend?
Also stechende Schmerzen sind es nicht dumm.
Das brennend auch nicht.
Das sind so messenstichartige Schmerzen.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
Nein, nur ich habe keinen Schmerz im 10, jetzt steige Schmerzen.
Das würde ich sagen momentan so bei 5.
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten
und immer im Laufe der Zeit sich beistragt.
Wie sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen die wieder weg?
Ganz weggehen, tun sie nicht, aber bei bestimmten Bewegungen
tun sie noch mehr weh.
Als Auslöser beschreiben Sie die Bewegung.
Aus dieser Bewegung gibt es noch Auslöser.
Weitere Auslöser, aus der Bewegung?
Nein.
Sie haben gesagt, sie nehmen bei Bedarf die Schmerzhameliten ein.
Gibt es noch etwas, was die Schmerzen liegen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Wenn ich mich hinlege und mich nicht bewege,
dann sind die Schmerzen deutlich weniger.
Wenn ich aufstehe oder mich bewege, dann kommen die Schmerzen stärker zurück.
Haben Sie sich friedlich?
Lieber habe ich nicht gehabt.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Atomnot?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Bis diese Schmerzen kamen, habe ich gut geschlafen.
Aber hin und wieder mache ich die Schmerzen auf.
Tritten die Schmerzen auch nachts auf?
Ja, auch nachts im Schlaf.
Haben Sie wegen der Schmerzen schon mal eine Art?
Nein, ich habe bisher nicht wegen der Schmerzen aufgesucht.
Haben Sie schon mal solche Schmerzen gehabt?
Nein, solche Schmerzen kenne ich nicht.
Sie sind ganz neu.
Haben Sie noch irgendwelche Beschwerden?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit abgenommen?
Nein, er ist gleich geblieben.
Schwitzen Sie nachts?
Ich meine Sie das.
Ich meine Sie das?
Auf der Brust wird es ein bisschen feucht.
Aber nachts ist es damit nicht gemeint.
Ich will es nur erwähnen.
Nach Schweiß ist etwas anderes.
Ja, nach Schweiß habe ich geblattet.
Leibung ist unter nachts.
Was ist nach Schweiß?
Nach Schweiß ist etwas anderes.
Schwitzen Sie nachts?
Ja, aber eine ganz bestimmte Menge.
Nach Schweiß bezeichnet man so viel Schwitzen,
dass die Kleidung oder Bett nachts wird.
Wenn man nachts aufsteht, Kleidung wechseln muss
oder Bettwäsche neumert.
Das ist nach Schweiß.
Wenn man nur ein bisschen feucht wird,
dann ist das normal.
Okay.
Leiden Sie an chronische
oder Vorerkrankungen?
Ich habe einen Diabetes,
wo ich Tabletten nehmen muss.
Der Blutdruck ist ein bisschen hoch.
Aber da habe ich momentan keine Tabletten für.
Sonst habe ich nichts mehr.
Wie weit man haben die Diabetes?
Deshalb habe ich meinen Hausarzt vor 5 Jahren festgestellt.
Und Blutdruck?
Ich habe das selber gemessen.
Seit einem halben Jahr habe ich den Eindruck,
der Blutdruck ist ein bisschen hoch.
Keine feste Diabetes.
Ich habe keine Diabetes.
Nein, da nehme ich auch keine Tabletten für.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, als Jugendliche hat man mir den Blinddarm entfernt.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie
irgendwelche wesentliche Erkrankungen?
Was wollen Sie wissen, wie es ist?
Meine Mutter hatte Gebärmutterkrebs.
Ihr Vater und Geschwister sind gesund?
Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Aber mein Vater lebt noch und hat keine Probleme.
Ist Ihre Tochter auch gesund?
Sie ist gesund.
Warum?
Weil ich nicht bin.
Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Ich bin gesund.
Gehen Sie regelmäßig zum Frauenarzt?
Ja, vor sechs Monaten war ich das letzte Mal beim Frauenarzt.
Alles in Ordnung?
Ja, so weit meine Pynecologin, das gesagt hat, sei alles in Ordnung.
Wann war der letzte Monatsblutung?
Ich bin schon längst daraus.
Ich bin ja auch in Ordnung.
Ich habe nicht mehr die ganze Zeit mitgegeben.
Ich bin schon längst daraus.
Ich bin ja 61.
Ich habe keine Blutung mehr.
Ich bin in der Menopause.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stundagen?
Ja, hier und wieder ist der mal fest.
Aber je nachdem, was ich esse, wird er wieder normal.
Gibt es etwas, was Sie wenig belastet?
Nein.
Sie meinen, ob ich Stress habe?
Ja, beim Arbeiten der Familie.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, nehmen Sie regelmäßig
von der Beide bedarf Medikamente ein?
Wie gesagt, für den Zucker
nehme ich momentan mit Formin ein.
Momentan sind das 500 Milligramm Tabletten.
Ich nehme eine morgens in den Abend ein.
Und sonst habe ich keine weiteren Tabletten.
Ich nehme Schmerz mit der Weltschmerz.
Nehmen Sie ein.
Wie viele Milligramm?
Das sind 400 Milligramm Tabletten, die ich für eine Apotheke bekommen habe.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich kaufe nicht.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich mag keinen Alkohol.
Ich habe keinen Alkohol.
Bei Ihnen ist es ein Alergym bekannt?
Ja, Paprikaalergie habe ich.
Aber sonst wüsste ich nicht.
Wie äußert sich die Alergie?
Wenn ich grünen Paprika esse,
dann kriege ich sofort Luftnot,
Rötung im Gesicht.
Frau Müller, meinerseits habe ich die wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Müssten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich möchte nur geholfen haben,
dass die Schmerzen auswirken.
Okay.
Ja, ich gebe Ihnen natürlich
ein Mittel, um die Schmerzen zu liefern.
Aber erstmal,
ich möchte Sie sagen,
wir müssen die richtige Diagnose feststellen.
Deswegen würde ich Sie
erstmal körperlich untersuchen.
Danach einfach untersuchen.
Planen, für Sie,
wie eine Rundtieruntersuchung.
Ich möchte auch
etwas körperlich machen.
einen,
wenn wir etwas besonders in Röntgen sehe,
dann vielleicht
kann ich auch eine Röntgen,
oder MRT-Untersuchung
vereinlassen.
Nach der Ergebnisse
gebe ich Besprüche mir nochmal.
Okay.
Da hatten zwei Kollegen Fragen.
Der einen hatte gefragt, ob kribbeln in den Beinen,
nein, kein kribbeln.
Haben Sie Schwerhe in Ihrem Beinen bemerkt?
Nein, keine Schwäche.
Haben Sie in der Saison bemerkt,
dass Sie nervös tat, unrihe Möglichkeit,
konzentration, Schwerhe, Leistung verlöst?
Nein, auch nicht.
Ich habe noch ein paar Minuten.
Ich kann die Portion hübsch gehen auf.
Klar.
Wer bietet mehr, wer hat noch eine Frage?
Um etwas Schweres getragen,
vor der ich meistens aufgetreten bin.
Ich kann mich nicht so erinnern.
Haben Sie vielleicht Veränderungen
der Borust festgestellt?
Ja.
Ich war ja vor einem halben Jahr beim Frauenarzt.
Er hatte das auch abgetastet.
Ich hatte eine Mammografie.
Da ist nichts Auffälliges gewesen.
Es gibt auch keine Rötchen?
Nein, keine Einziehung und keine Rötung.
War eine sehr gute Idee.
Okay.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine Patiente vorstellen.
Eine Patientin?
Ja.
Es geht um Frau Britt Müller.
Sie ist 63 Jahre Patiente.
Sie ist Büro-Angestellter.
Sie hat eine
Veränderung.
Sie klagt über Lumbargie seit 3-4 Wochen.
Die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten.
Sie ist im Laufe der Zeit verstarzt.
Sie beschreibt die Schmerzen als stechend.
Schmerzen zu. Wegen der Schmerzen hat sie Durchlappe, hat sie Parasomie.
Um einen Durchlaftürungen.
Durchlaftürungen, genau.
Der Vorerkrankungen liegt seit fünf Jahren Diabetes mellitus vor.
Typ 1 oder Typ 2?
Vor fünf Jahren festgestellt, Typ 2.
Gut.
Wir haben auch gesagt, dass sie Arterialikkatin hat, aber deswegen hat sie noch nie ein Arzt besucht.
Der Familienanamnese liegt mutterlicherseits der Uteruskalzino.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und sie nimmt regelmäßig Metformin 500 mg morgens und abends ein bei Bedarf über Gruppen 400 mg.
Sonst, das war es nach den bisherigen, ja.
Ja, nie. Gehen wir mal weiter, Schritusche.
Sie haben sie untersucht?
Ja, ich habe schon die Patienten untersucht.
Weißte, wie viel habe ich bei den Untersuchungen?
Ja, die Lendenwirbelsäule, der Lumbale Bereich, Lendenwirbelsäule, LWS, ist klopfschmerzhaft.
Klopfschmerzhaft.
Und die Schmerzintensität nimmt es bei Bewegung hin und her zu.
Und so die weitere Untersuchung, abdominell, gibt keine Auffälligkeiten und sie haben auch keine Lymphknoten oder so getastet.
Und dann haben sie auch nur Blut abgenommen.
Und im Blut sehen sie, ich sage mal, ein Kreatinien von 2,5, ja.
Und Leukozytten von 4.500, normal.
Ein HB von 8,5 und Trombozytten von 90.000.
Anämie und Trombospuppe, Herr.
Ja, hat sie.
Und Gluckenschmerzen.
Ja, und wegen der Rückenschmerzen haben sie jetzt noch einen Röntgen gemacht.
Man macht einfach umzuschauen, ob da was Auffälliges ist.
Und die Radiologen sagen, ein Wirbelkörper der LWK4, der ist gebrochen, frakturiert.
Und man sieht viele Osteolysen.
Ja, und man empfiehlt eine weitere CT-Kontrolle.
Mhm.
Was machen wir jetzt damit?
Also, die Hauptaussage sind Osteolysen.
Was Osteolysen sind, wissen Sie, ne?
Ja, ja.
Löcher im Knochen.
Und der LWK4er, der ist frakturiert, der ist gebrochen.
Deshalb hat es ja auch die Schmerzen in dem Bereich.
Ja.
Gut.
Und jetzt müssen wir wissen, was sind denn das für Dinger, was für Osteolysen sind das?
Wenn jemand im Knochen Osteolysen hat,
dann ist es die einfachste Methode, um das abzuklären.
Woran muss man immer denken?
Einfachste Erkrankung, wie immer in den Knochen geht.
Osteoporose?
Osteoporose macht keine Osteolysen.
Das macht eine Osteopenie, sagt man.
Da hat einer richtig getippt, ja?
Multiplismylom.
Genau.
Das ist die erste Erkrankung, an die man immer denken muss, wenn jemand Osteolysen hat.
Weil das kann man sehr einfach abklären.
Was muss man dafür machen?
Für Multiplismylom, bei Bedacht?
Antibodinbulut?
Ne, noch nicht.
Man macht eine sogenannte Serum-Elektrophorese.
Ah, ja.
Und in der Serum-Elektrophorese kann man dann sehen,
ob im Bereich der Gamma-Sacke ein M-Gradient vorliegt oder nicht.
Und wie der M-Gradient ist bei dieser Dame sehr hoch.
Was haben wir also schon mal ganz schnell herausgefunden?
Bei ihr besteht der Verdacht auf ein Multiplismylom.
Das ist jetzt unsere Verdachtstättenose.
Und jetzt müssen wir darauf aufbauen.
Wie geht man davor?
Welche Untersuchungen sind notwendig?
Und was muss man alles machen,
damit man dann diese Erkrankung 100%ig gesichert hat.
Und damit man auch eine geeignete Therapie dafür durchführen kann.
Kennen Sie sich bisschen mit Multiplismylom aus?
Ich habe einen Fall gehört, hier mit meinen Kollegen.
Aber ich erinnere mich nicht.
Genau.
Okay.
Nicht schlimm.
Mein paar ist Augen.
Augen, Augen, Augen.
Hatten Sie mal erzählt, richtig.
Also, Multiplismylom, da läuft vieles serologisch ab.
Ein Multiplismylom, nach der auffälligen oder pathologischen Seromelektrophorese,
kann man eine sogenannte Immunfixation machen.
Und die Immunfixation sagt uns, welche Gruppe von Myolom wir haben.
Ein, ein, in der Immunfixation banden für IGG oder EGA oder IGM oder IGD sein kann.
Oder aber Leichtketten, ja, Kappa oder Lambda Leichtketten, ja.
Und je nachdem, welche Banden in der Immunfixation so richtig ausgeprägt sind,
sagt dann der Labormediziner, es besteht der Verdacht auf ein multiplismylom.
Vom Typ sagen wir mal IGG plus Lambda Leichtketten.
Ja, dann haben wir schon mal den Namen dieser Erkrankung.
Sonst kann man die Erkrankung nicht so spezifizieren.
Im zweiten Schritt, ja, wenn man die Immunfixation gemacht hat,
muss man jetzt die Antikörper, die sogenannte Immunglobuline, quantitativ bestimmen.
Das wissen Sie, was quantitativ gemeint ist, das sagt der Deutsche meisten immer so.
Quantitative Bestimmung der Immunglobuline.
Das bedeutet, dass man im Blut die absolute Zahl der Immunglobuline einfach bestimmt.
Wie hoch ist der Wert, ja?
Zum Beispiel, wir haben jetzt gesagt, das ist ein IGG Lambda.
Wie hoch ist der Wert für IGG im Serum?
Und wie ihr da, diese Patientin hat ein Wert von 3900 Milligramm Kotil.
Ja, das ist sehr, sehr hoch.
Und die Lambda Leichtketten, da sagen Sie, das ist so bei 800.
Der Normalwert liegt unter 100, muss man wissen.
Dementsprechend haben wir pathologisch erhöhte Werte für IGG und für Leichtketten Lambda.
Das ist jetzt die serologische Abklärung. Das ist jetzt damit abgeschlossen.
Jetzt muss man als Weiteres noch eins machen.
Das hatte die Kollegin sehr schnell vermutet oder ein Kollege, aber es kommt erst später.
Das war die diagnostische Knochenmarkspunktion.
Warum? Wie stellen Sie sich denn so ein Myolom vor? Was passiert denn bei der Erkrankung?
Haben Sie sich damit mal so ein bisschen beschäftigt, was bei Myolom im Knochenmark vorgeht?
Die, ja, die, die, ich glaube, nicht, bis am, am, am leut, ansammlung?
Das muss nicht immer sein. Das muss nicht immer sein, aber das kann dazu führen.
Im regulieren Ansammlung, ja.
Ja, nein, nein, nein, nein. Sie müssen im Knochenmark, müssen sich das so vorstellen.
Das ist eine Plasmacel-Erkrankung. Ein Multiplussmülom ist eine Plasmacel-Erkrankung.
Und das ist nichts anderes als eine monoklonale Vermehrung von Plasmaceln.
Die Plasmacellen, die Prü-Plasmacellen, nimmt in den Knochenmark zu.
Die anderen Zellen hat keine Platz mehr.
Man spricht von einer Verdrängung.
Durch die vermehrte Plasmacel-Vermehrung, Bildung,
wird die normale Bildung der anderen Blutreihen,
die rote Reihe, die weiße Reihe oder die Blutplättchen,
wird dadurch verdrängt.
Und jetzt klärt sich auch, warum diese Patientin ein HB von 8, noch etwas hatte
und die Trombozyten nur bei 90.000 sind.
Die muss also eine Verdrängung von haben.
Und deshalb müssen Sie jetzt eine Knochenmark-Funktion machen.
Wissen Sie so die Kriterien für eine Manifestation eines multiplen
Myolomens, weil nicht jeder M-Gradient in der Elektrophorese
oder gar ein M-Gradient in der Gamma-Fraktion in der Elektrophorese
und nicht jede Erhöhung von Immunglobulinen und nicht jede
Immunfixation bedeutet gleich ein multiples Myolom.
Dafür müssen bestimmte Kriterien vorliegen.
Eins der Kriterien ist, oder man spricht von den sogenannten Crap-Kriterien.
Das ist einmal das Calcium C, das R für Renal- oder Rennen für die Niere,
das A für Anämie, Hämoglobin und das B bricht für Australysen, Bone-Legions.
Und diese vier Faktoren, die bestimmen, ob ein behandlungsbedürftiges Myolom
vorliegt oder nicht.
Und diese Patientin hat schon mal Osthyrolysen.
Die hat eine Anämie.
Dann haben wir schon mal zwei Kriterien.
Dann hat sie auch noch eine Niere-Nähen-Suffizienz.
Die hatten Kreatinien von 2,5.
Dann hat sie schon drei.
Und Calcium war normal.
Das vierte fehlt, ist aber nicht schlimm.
Ein Kriterium reicht aus, damit man von einer behandlungsbedürftigen
Myolomerkrankung sprechen kann.
Und was noch wichtig ist, im Knochenmark sagt man,
ist ein Multiplusmyolom nur dann manifest,
wenn die Plasmacellen über 10 % sind.
Wenn sie nur 2, 3 % Plasmacellen haben,
dann ist es laut den Kriterien im Knochenmark nicht so sicher damit.
Das kann aber manchmal passieren.
Wissen Sie, warum?
Weil das Myolom, das ist nicht durchgehend über alle im Knochenmark
gleich, sondern diese klonalen Zellen, die können sich hier
vermehren, da wieder nicht, drüben wieder ja und so weiter.
Und je nachdem, wo man die Diagnostik macht,
man kann in so ein Myolom reinstechen,
man kann aber auch ein gesundes Areal treffen bei der Knochenmarkspunktion.
Deshalb schließt eine, ich sage mal, unaussellige Knochenmarkspunktion
oder keine relevante Plasmacell im Knochenmark
ein Multiplusmyolom in dieser Konstellation nicht aus.
Also, dann machen wir eine Diagnostische Knochenmarkspunktion
und wir sehen, da sind 80 % Plasmacellen.
Und damit haben wir die Erkrankung damit bewiesen.
Jetzt müssen Sie noch 2 Sachen machen.
Sie müssen wissen, wo überall ist denn die Erkrankung?
Was können Sie dafür machen?
Wir haben gesagt, die Erkrankung spielt sich im Knochenmark ab.
Wenn Sie wissen wollen, wo überall die Erkrankung vorhanden ist,
müssen Sie also was machen?
Früher hat man den gesamten Körper geröntcht
und das haben wir damals als sogenanntes Pariser Schema bezeichnet.
Mittlerweile sagt man, das ist zu alt, das macht man nicht mehr.
Im Zeiten der modernen Technik macht man eine Laudos-Computer-Tomographie.
Die kriegen ein CT, wo der Kopf mit abgebildet wird,
wo die Halswirbelsäule die Arme bis zu den Ellenbogen-Gelenken,
Bauchbereich, Becken, Oberschenkel bis zu den Knien.
Eine Synthographie macht man beim Mühlung eher nicht.
Das gehört nicht zu den Empfehlungen, zu den Leitlinien.
Aber eine CT-Untersuchung gehört mit dazu.
Und so in den letzten Jahren hat sich auch eingebürgert,
sage ich mal, in die Leitlinien,
dass man eine Magnetoresonanz-Tomographie,
eine Kernspintomographie von der gesamten Wirbelsäule macht.
Man spricht MRT-Holesbein.
Gesamte Wirbelsäule MRT, damit man dann sehen kann,
ob es in allen Bereichen Infiltrationen gibt
oder ob zum Beispiel auch extra meduläre Myolome gibt.
Myolome können sich auch mal außerhalb des Knochenmarkens bilden.
Dann spricht man von extra medulären Myolome-Manifestationen.
Und wenn Sie alles gemacht haben,
dann bildet sich ein sogenanntes Stadium der Erkrankung.
Und davon abhängig machen Sie dann eine Therapie.
Und die Therapie, die hängt einmal davon ab, wie alt der Patient ist.
Patienten unter 70 Jahren können prinzipiell
autolog Stampheld transplantiert werden.
Die Patientin ist wie alt gewesen?
63.
63. Also käme sie für eine Transplantation in Frage.
Wenn Sie das denn wählen natürlich, man muss das mit dir besprechen.
Aber auf jeden Fall braucht sie eine Induktionstherapie.
Man sagt eine Chemo-Immuntherapie.
Und irgendwann dann Stammzell-Sammlung
und dann eine autologische Stammzell-Transplantation.
Was eine autologische Transplantation ist, wissen Sie, ne?
Ja.
Autolog ist, wenn man selber Stammzellen hergibt.
Und fremd bedeutet Allogen.
Das heißt, jemand anderes stellt das zur Verfügung
und dann kriegt man das zugeführt.
Da gibt es jetzt viele verschiedene Therapieformen,
die Medikamente jetzt alle aufzuzählen,
macht jetzt, denke ich, keinen Sinn,
weil das mehr hematologisches Spezialwissen ist.
Aber bei den Prüfungen kann eben immer drankommen,
multiplis myelom.
Und was macht das für Auffälligkeiten, eben die Osteolysen?
Und meistens fällt so etwas mit Schmerzen
und dann kommt die Fraktur auf.
Und jetzt haben Sie diese Patientin schön diagnostiziert.
Und wenn Sie kein Hematolobe, Onkologe sind,
dann schicken Sie diese Patientin zum Hematologen.
Und wegen dieser Fraktur an dem LWK4
müssen Sie die Patientin in einer Strahlentherapie vorstellen.
Das muss bestrahlt werden.
Erstens, damit die Schmerzen nachlassen.
Und zweitens, damit dieser Wirbelkörper nicht instabil wird
und die Hinterkante nicht angegriffen wird.
Und als Letztes muss man bei Osteolysen,
egal welcher Erkrankung,
sogenannte Bisphosphonate geben.
Das sind so Knochenaufbaumedikamente,
die dafür sorgen,
dass Calcium in die Knochen aufgenommen wird.
Zum Zweiten hemmt dieses Medikament die Aktivität der Osteoklasten.
Das sind die Zellen, die Knochen abbauen.
Und man sagt, als Drittes wird das Medikament antitumorproliferativ.
Das bedeutet, dass Tumorzellen in ihrer Aktivität dadurch gehemmt werden.
Das Medikament hat aber eine Nebenwirkung,
darüber sollten sie immer informiert sein.
Was machen Bisphosphonate?
Was ist berüchtigt?
Was ist darunter immer zu berücksichtigen?
Das kann sogenannte Kiefernekosen hervorrufen.
Oder Osteonekosen,
überwiegend im Ober- oder Unterkieferbereich.
Meistens dann, wenn an den Zähnen
irgendwelche Probleme vorliegen,
Granulome oder Parodontose
oder Caries.
Deswegen sagen wir immer unseren Patienten,
bevor sie dieses Medikament bekommen,
müssen sie einmal zum Zahnarzt gehen.
Der muss alles einmal gründlich untersuchen.
Und alles, was gemacht werden muss,
erstmal vernünftig behandeln.
Und wenn er mit seiner Arbeit fertig ist,
dann kriegt der Patient diese Bisphosphonate.
Da gibt es verschiedene Formen.
Es gibt welche, die gibt man einmal alle vier Wochen
mit vier Milligramm.
Dann gibt es welche, die gibt man auch alle vier Wochen.
Aber das sind 90 Milligramm Aredia.
Die Lauszeit ist wiederum ein bisschen anders.
Und das ist aber auch wiederum etwas Speziales.
Nur, dass wir davon mal gehört haben.
Bisphosphonate, Kiefernekose.
Nicht vergessen.
Und Osteolysen brauchen immer Bisphosphonate.
Und das wirft auch bisschen Schmerzreduzieren.
Ja?
Gut.
Krageln.
Ein bisschen Spezialwissen für euch.
Ja, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, ja, Milligramm,
Multiplismillom,
ist jetzt keine Erkrankung,
die sehr selten ist.
Und so eine Elektrophorese
oder aber so einen M-Gardienten
in der Elektrophorese,
das stellen meistens zu Hausärzte fest.
Und dann werden die Patientinnen mit Verdacht auch
und Multiplismillom in die Klinik geschickt.
Daran muss man immer denken.
Und natürlich, wenn jemand jetzt mit Osteolysen
mit einer Fraktur kommt,
müssen sie je nachdem,
welches Geschlecht vor ihnen sitzt,
ob es eine Frau ist oder ein Mann ist.
Natürlich, was die Kollegin vorhin gesagt hat,
ist, dass sie auch ein Mammarkard-Synom denken,
was sehr gerne Kauchenmetastasen macht,
oder aber bei Männern natürlich ein Prostatakrebs denken.
Ja?
Hätten sie jetzt eine unauffällige Elektrophorese gehabt,
dann hätten sie die Suche weitermachen müssen.
Ja?
Eine Computertomographie von Brust und Bauch.
Auch wenn die Patientin vor sechs Monaten beim Frauenarzt war,
die sie mal gynäkologisch untersuchen lassen,
eine Magenspiegelung machen,
eine Darmspiegelung machen
und je nachdem vielleicht auch noch eine Lungenspiegelung.
Weil auch Grundjahrkarzynome sehr gerne in die Knochen gehen.
Mhm.
Gut.
Irgendetwas unklageblieben?
Auch bei allen anderen?
Dankeschön.
Bitte.
Vielen Dank.
Ich muss Sie denn noch fragen?
Keine Frage.
War das zu schwer gewesen?
Alle Verstandenen, worüber wir gesprochen haben,
oder ist etwas unverständlich geblieben?
Doch, wir haben schon Verstanden.
Okay.
Gut.
Im letzten Fall haben wir viele Säntome,
hatten wir viele Säntome, ja,
wir haben ja viele Phosphorol,
Leber und so.
Jetzt haben wir nur ein Lumbargie.
Ja, ja.
Wie gesagt, Mühlen kann sich in vielen Art und Weisen bemerkbar machen.
Das kann sogar so weit gehen,
dass man mit einer Anämie einfach aufschlägt,
ohne dass man weiß, warum dieser Mensch eine Anämie hat.
Mhm.
Elektrophorese, darin wird man sehr schnell findet. Wenn das ein Myelomis haben Sie das mit
einer Blutentnahme sofort diagnostiziert. Da brauchen Sie weder als CT noch irgendetwas,
die haben schon sozusagen den Namen der Erkrankung herausgefunden, dann können Sie da drauf langsam
aufbauen. Und was Sie meinen mit der renalen Beteiligung und so weiter, das ist eher die
Ameloidose. Das sind so spezielle Formen, so Leichkettenmyelome, die Ameloidablagerungen
hervorrufen und es gibt eine spezielle Leichkettenamyeloidose. Das ist wiederum eine Erkrankung für
sich, wobei manche sagen, Ameloidose ist kein multiples Myelom, das darf man nicht gleichsetzen.
Das ist eine spezielle Erkrankung für sich und bei der Ameloidose muss man wissen,
dass die Patienten relativ rasch versterben. Die Komplikationen sind viel zu groß,
weil die Ameloidablagerungen als allererstes das Herz völlig kaputt machen. Schwächen
und die leiden meistens an einem totalen Nierenversagen, sind meistens dialysepflichtige
Patienten und haben eine schwere Herzinsuffizienz und die kompensieren sehr leicht und viele
wirksame Medikamente existieren für die Ameloidose. Das ist wiederum eine spezielle Sorte. Das kann
man irgendwann vielleicht auch noch mal behandeln, aber ich habe jetzt erst mal versucht, als einfachste
Form nur ein banales, multiples Myelom Typ IGG mit bisschen Lambda durchzuspielen.
Dann bedanke ich mich für so viele Zuhörer, wenn keine Fragen sind, dann können wir die Sitzung schließen.